Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier...
and welcome to The Somewhat-Impossible Markiplier Quiz.
Now I'm playing this game because number 1: it's my birthday, for real this time, no fooling...
Aaaannnd Number 2... I heard what this guy said about this game
And how he made it and how he got other people involved in it
and how it's his first flash animation project EVER!
And how he's really proud of it! He says, "My name is Nicholas Lovett, I have been watching your videos
"since Amnesia, and I loved your videos ever since. You're my idol, as you could say.
"And I'm one of your fans, maybe not your "biggest" fan, but I admire your work a lot.
"I had to rewatch some of your videos to get some of the information for the quiz, but it was worth it.
"Anyways, I'm 18 (as of now), and I'm new to this whole animation stuff. So for my first complete flash
"animation, I thought it turned out pretty well. I'd have to say my favorite video of yours is when you played
"Bewilder House with the clown. I couldn't stop myself from laughing in class.
"And yes I do watch your videos in school, because I need some entertainment XD.
"Anyways, enjoy the game! This is my way of giving back to the community!
"Also, some questions will be really easy, some will be hard, and some will require thinking outside the box.
"And some question answers might not be the one you think is the correct one.
"This game is dedicated to Mark, his fans, and my loving girlfriend, my Hand <3"
So thank you, Nicholas so much for making this.
And I wanna say that I don't think I've been observant enough about things that are made in the community.
I-I play like this leadership role where I try to guide you guys around but...
I i-it's dawned on me and I get very self-reflective about it you know like my birthday and I'm getting older
And I remember when I started, and I realized that there's so many small things like this!
And the reason I didn't find this one is because it's actually kinda low rated and it gets lost in the shuffle
Because of, you know, things that people make, you know, gets higher rating and gets up higher
But I found this one, and, you know, I-I don't care that it's low rated or anything because it's his first project and it's
Rough around the edges because h-he- it's the first thing he ever made a-and I don't care about that because he
MADE it for me!
Like someone took the time to actually MAKE something for me and also like the intro music is like my old outro music!
*In game music begins* If you listen! It's my old outro music that I used to do which was this thing that
Someone remixed a L O N G time ago and it's *pure joy* I L O V E IT SO MUCH!!
*Remixes of Marks screams and shouts*
Whoops! *Markiplier gibberish*
*More remixed Mark mating calls*
I lov- I LOVE THIS STUFF
I L O V E  I T
G O D I LOVE IT I love these cool things that people make for me I love the old things!!
I LOVE THE N E W THINGS!! I love it all and I haven't been, you know, like putting it out there for people to
see because I need to be the conduit for this stuff that's MADE FOR ME TO GET SEEN!
ALRIGHT! So wiTHOUT FURTHER ADO, LET'S GET INTO IT.
(This should go well!) Yeah... probably, old me
"What is Mark's real name?"
Mark "Team Edward" Fischbach
Mark Edward Fischbach
MarkiMoo *it should be imo*
Mark Edward Fischbeethoven
Well if I don't know my own name,  I am a sad pathetic lump.
Mark Edward Fischbach!
*happy ding*
OKAY
At least you're not going to be douchey with me!
"What did Mark want to do before he became a YouTuber?"
Male Stripper (fanservice af)
Comedian
Biomedical Engineer
or Dr. Nigel
OOOOOHHHHHHHH
That's a Surgeon Simulator reference! But also I kinda wanna either do "Male Stripper"
But I'm PRETTY sure I wanna be a Biomedical Engineer.
*happy ding*
Still do
"Who is Mark's greatest Hero?"
A) Superman B) The Blacksmith
C) His Dad (aww) or D) Booker DuWitt
Oh who is he- who is he from?!
Oh that sounds so familiar! (Bioshock: Infinite)
Was that The Evil Within?! Ah I think it was The Evil Within!
I'm not 100% sure (Bioshock: Infinite, hun)
But my dad is my greatest hero, by far.
Alright. "What was Mark's first video?"
A) Amnesia Re- ohhh this would depend- oh no wait. On the options here, ok it would depend!
'Cuz my first channel that I had it would have been a different answer, but on THIS one that you're watching it
on, I BELIEVE the first one I uploaded was the Amnesia Reaction Compilation. B I N G!
Alright. "Where did the phrase 'WHERE'S THE BLACKSMITH???!!!' come from?"
His mouth, TV, another YouTuber or  Some Guy In A Village? (giggles)
Which would PROBABLY be more accurate because it started from a rampaging monster wandering through
the halls of (in a funny voice) Eleusis
Oh man, it was actually funny- it's funny how much this phrase still carries through to this day
Uh, because I was just at VidCon and Jack, while we were hanging out, would often like, just
reference it for no reason like,
"WHEEEEEERE'S THE BLAAAAAACKSMITH???!!!"
"WHEEEERRREEE'S (giggling) the blaaaacksmith???!!!"
So I think- I think it originated from my mouth but I'm- not 100% sure about that.
*happy ding*
Okay! Good enough for me
"How many subscriber milestones has Mark posted videos about?"
WELL I DON'T KNOW!!!
I DON'T KNOW WHEN THIS VIDEO WAS POSTED
OOOOHHHHH GOSH
"This is the right answer because none of the answers have been D yet"
I WANNA CHOOSE THAT ONE
BUUUUUUUUT... 26
(Clicks wrong answer)
Ah s h i t
(wrong answer again)
AH GAWD
*Markimoo screams*
OH NO *Background noise of Mark saying "Don't Move"*
(Don't Move)
(Don't Move x2)
(Don't Move x3)
(Don't Move x4)
(I didn't move)
*giggling*
Oh gawd I failed already I'm so bad ;-;
Awh man but tha- that means it was the i-it was the trolly one.
OH GAWD
*Accidentally clicks the wrong answer*
Oh shit gawd dammit
Okay. "This is the right answer because none of the answers have been D yet."
B O I N K
Okay... "What is Mark's greatest fear?"
A) Waking up to 0 subscribers on his channel
B) Manipedi
D) Manicures
or C) Mannequins *giggles*
WHAT'S WRONG WITH A GOOD OL' MANIPEDI
how 'bout mannequins. Okay.
"What University did Mark go to? (Go Bighorns!)
"University of Phoenix, University of Pennsylvania, Furman University or  Eastern Colorado University?"
NONE OF THESE ARE CORRECT
*mark contemplates life*
NONE OF THESE ARE RIGHT
*bewilderment*
I-
*wtf mode*
I WENT TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CINCINNATI
Is- Are they trying to make a joke about me going to the University of Phoenix???
*It's the wrong answer* shit.
AHHHHHH GOOOOD (Mark's in game voice: "I must end my career here.") N OOO O
DON'T END MY CAREER
IT'S ONLY JUST BEGUN
...four years ago...
whatever
alright, hang on. Gotta get back to it
boink, boink, okay.
*Clicks "correct" answer*
*happy ding*
WHAT EASTERN COLORADO
I DIDN'T GO THERE
"How many parts were in Mark's The Last of Us series?"
I DON'T KNOW
I THINK 12
BUT(T)
*Clicks wrong answer* Oh no. *clicks another wrong answer* oh go- *Markimoo screaming*
Gawd dammit!
It's gonna be a trolly game
It's gonna be a trolly game x2
It's gonna be a trolly game x3
And that's okay...
I can do this.
It's fine
I got this
Everybody hold on.
Too many to count- y e u p
Okay. "Does Mark play games without recording in his spare time?"
Yeeesss I do
"What game did Mark fail the most at, and should play again?"
WELL
GAWD DAMMIT I KNOW WHEN THIS GAME WAS MADE
It was back in the "Vanish" era of horrible vanishness
But WHY is there 3 Vanishes?
And 1 Five Night's at Freddy"s????
*panicked screams*
Do I click on this? Is it a joke? Is it am joke? Is it all for joke?
*clicks wrong answer*
*Raging Markimoo*
AHHH COME ON
I'M TRYIN MY BEST HERE, MAN
I'M TRYING MY BEST
Okay. Alright. Hang on...
Wait... *Mark gibberish*
Yes.. *clicks FNAF*
*happy ding*
WWW HHH YYY
WHY THAT ONE
I feel more advantaged
Well I guess, technically, in the number of times I died
FNAF WOULD be correct okay.
"Which Custom Story playthrough of Amnesia did Tiny Box Tim be born?"
That was A Late Night Drink which is my Amnesia custom story I've ever don- oh gawd
"In his Twitch Livestreams, how much has Mark currently donated to Charity?"
Now this was not me personally, this was all of you guys
and, I don't know when this was
And the only difference is the cents?????
*Interracial man contemplates answer choices*
UUUUUHHHHH H *clicks right answer*
*screams of happiness*
OKAY! GOT IT! Okay...
alright
"What is Markiplier's dog named?"
OH MY GOSH
THIS IS BEFORE I HAD CHICA
OHHH Chica no don't get up, it's okay this is before I had Chica!
This is back when Buddi-  OH MY GAWD
BUDDI
Buddi with an I because, Buddy, we thought it was a boy
But then later discovered that it was a girl sorry we weren't looking closely apparently
*ding*
yusss okay
"Where was Mark born?"
A) In Hawaii B) On Earth C) In a hospital or D) On a military base
WELL
ALL OF THESE ARE TECHNICALLY CORRECT
I don't know if I was actually born on a military base
my dad was in the military but I don't know if it was ooonnn the baaaassseeee....
I-in Hawaii???
*wrong answer* Dammit
*wrong answer again*
DAMMIT
On Earth... *clicks wrong answer*
AAAHHHH GAWD
*Screeches* F U C K
*In game Mark talking about sexy ducks*
THAT DUCK IS NOT SEXY STOP IT IT'S NOT A SEXY DUCK
Gawd dammit how do I keep doing this I keep getting like, I keep getting u-u-uh
ALL THREE WRONG
ON ONE QUESTION
AND THEN
FRICKEN
BALLSING IT UP
ALL OVER THE PLACE SO ON EARTH
YEAH O K A Y
"What is not one of Mark's Impossible Let's Plays?"
The Sodabatch Challenge
I don't even know what that is...
okay
"How many videos are currently in Mark's horror playlist? Just choose the right answer this time."
w h a t O.o
O H G A W D
OHHH G A W D
Okay so it means the RIGHT answer so...
*the moment of truth*
*happy ding*
Y E S
OKAY
"What are the 'little kiddies'?"
Those are Santa's Elves
Don't ask questions they're the Santa's elves
Alright "Which game has it's very own custom Markiplier Mod?"
That was SCP!
Oh yeah SCP had a Markiplier mod I should play that game gawd I should
And there's prolly a lot of people out there like "YUSSS!! PLAY SCP AGAIN!!!"
Even I played like- I got like 50 episodes of it but if
there's new updates, I'll definietly play it okay.
Okay, "Who is SCP-173?"
Wasn't that Billy Bob??? That was Billy Bob
*clicks wrong answer*
oh dammit
Ah I thought it was Billy Bob but: A creepy voodoo doll looking creature
Someone I don't want to be around
My worst nightmare
ALL OF THESE COULD APPLY
Someone I do- *clicks right answer* Y E S
O K A Y "Did Mark cheat sometimes while play SCP Containment Breach?"
N O O O O O
YOU SAW N O T H I N G
N O T H I N G
*clicks "correct" answer*
YOU SAW NOTHING
Alright. "When did Markiplier upload his first Drunk Minecraft Episode?"
Okay...
It would've have been 2012 I'm not sure whether it was the 8th or the 9th...
*thinking aloud in gibberish*
I have NO idea...
It- *clicks right answer*
Y E S
OKAY
"In which episode of Outlast: Whistleblower did Mark see something so gruesome and horrible that he had to be reminded of [it]?"
oh gawd...
There wasn't that many episodes of Whistleblower because it was just DLC...
I believe there was only five
So it was towards the end
YOU ALL KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT RIGHT?
IT WAS P R E T T Y BAD
So it wasn't the first two...
and it wasn't the last...
so it must be 4
*happy ding*
Y E S
"Press B to-" B L O W
Okay. "How does Mark usually start his video?" A) "Helloooo everybody my name is markiplier"
*giggles* B) By looking at the camera first then saying answer A
C) Pointing and shouting answer A
D) Staring heavily into your eyes
I'm pretty sure pointing and shouting *clicks wrong answer*
a w h dammit
Looking at the camera? *happy ding*
Y A Y
Okay. "Which game did Mark rage the most at and should play again?"
WELL GAWD DAMMIT
Okay based on the last- There's a lot of Vanish here
I think people want me to play Vanish
Some people- I BEAT Vanish I finally beat Vanish
But some people say I didn't OFFICIALLY beat Vanish
Because I beat the UPDATED version of Vanish which made it easier
AND THAT'S B U L L S H I T
I B E A T IT
F A I R
AND
S Q U A R E
So you can't really say I didn't
Surgeon Simulator? *happy ding*
Okay.
I haven't play it in forever...
"Which game did Mark have most fun with?"
"Every game except [for] Vanish." Yeah...
That sounds about right *happy ding*
Okay. "Which gmod gamemode has Mark played and recorded the most of?"
I would believe Prop Hunt
I'm pretty sure which we need to play even more of (agreed)
BOINK *happy ding*
Okay. "In the first episode of Octodad: Dadliest Catch, where was the setting of the game in the beginning?"
It was a wedding.
...It was a wedding yeah.
Oh the DLC was at the resturant yeah.
BOINK *happy ding*
Okay yeah. "Where has Mark always wanted to go-" SPACE
*clicks wrong answer*
*high pitched man squeals*
I WANNA GO TO SPACE
I didn't eve SEE what the other answers were
Is there something else I wanted to do???
gawd dammit brb *time jump*
Where does Mark wanna go?
The Nostromo which is from Alien Isolation I believe
DIDNEY WORL- AHHH DIDNEY WORL
I WANNA GO TO DIDNEY WORL!!
Y U S
Alright. "How do you get famous on Youtube?"
A) Start a let's drive channel
B) StranGER BABY MAKEOUT
C) C I R C L E  J E R K
OH MY GAWD THIS IS FROM MY FAVORITE SKETCH WE'VE EVER DONE
OH MAAANNNN
THIS ONE SEEMS REALLY WEIRD IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THAT ONE
It's call uh- I believe it's called "How to Get Famous on Youtube" litterally the name of the question
And the answer OF COURSE is Circle jerk, while kissing a baby in a car
which, admittedly, sounds REALLY WEIRD if you HAVEN'T seen the video SOOOO
*giggling* watch the video
*happy ding*
*giggling* it's okay...
Alright "Why did Mark cry a little?" (little is an understatement
Ohhhh so many reasons...
I was playing Dreadhalls, yeah
I was playing Vanish, maybe
He got something in his eye, probably
It was his important message video,  UHM
*sighs*
Just knowing your schtick on Vanish
*wrong answer*
dammit
I got something in my eye? *wrong answer*
dammit...
I did - I did tear up a bit at Dreadhalls...
*happy ding*
*happy screeches*
OKAY
"What was the 'Scariest Game in Years'?"
That was FNAF
"On December 25th, what will Mark become?"
Santaplier- *wrong answer*
N O
W H A T
BUT THAT'S WHAT I WOULD'VE BEEN
AH DAMMIT GAWD DAMMIT Alright
"On December 25, what will Mark become?"
*mumbling the answer choices* Wilfred- it's WilFERD thank you.
full of presents and gifts...
well if it's not saNTAPLIER WHAT DO I DO
well actually, no, that's not what I do because I haven't done it in a long time
full of presents and gifts? *happy ding*
okay yeah okay
"How many times did Mark fail in the original Markiplier Quiz?"
I DON'T K N O W
A LOT LESS THAN I FAILED IN THIS ONE
Probably 4, considering that's the most *happy ding*
Okay yeah. "Markiplier is King of..."
THE SQUIRRELS *wrong answer*
WHAT I'M KING OF THE SQUIRRELS
NOOOO GAWD DAMMIT
The castle, ocean, Youtube...? *happy ding*
I'M NOT THE KING OF YOUTUBE NO WAY
"What is Mark so fascinated with?"
SPAAAAAAACCCCEEEEE?????
*happy ding*
T H A N K  Y O U
Finally you get it
"Which Episode of Alien: Isolation was Markiplier sleep deprived?"
I DON'T KNOOOWWWWW
HOW AM I TO KNOOOOWWWW
7, 6, 8, 9.....
6? *wrong answer*
7?! *happy ding*
OKAY THANK YOU
"What did Markiplier use the most of in Alien: Isolation?"
A) Save stations B) his flamethrower C) noisemakers or D) a revolver...
I don't even know if there WAS a revolver in the game...
I used a flamethrower but I didn't have enough fuel...
I actually did not use the noisemakers that much because I wasn't very strateigic in the game
So I'm assuming I save way too much. *happy ding*
Okay thank you.
"Who was the protagonist in Alien: Isolation?"
Th- that was Ripley's daughter I believe, Ripley Jr.
*happy ding*
Okay
"Was there a cutscene at the end of the credits on Alien: Isolation?"
*MARKIMOO POWERS ACTIVATE*
YES??????
MAYBE?
I believe- wasn't there something actually Ripley *mumbling*
Yes? *wrong answer*
OOOOHHHHHH
*ingame Mark screams mating call*
*irl Mark returns the call*
DAMMIT
okay...
NO
okay
"In The Evil Within, what were all the names of the main characters?"
Booker DuW- OH IT WAS!!
IT WAS EVIL WITHIN! BOOKER DUWITT, JOJO, KIDMAN LESLIE, AND RUVIK
I'm glad they put JoJo- are they going to accept MY naming of JoJo?
Because I don't think Joe has any other name but JoJo at this point...
uhhhhhh
*laughs*
I- I think
I think his name actually was Sebastian but I kept calling him Booker DuWitt
*happy ding*
YAAAAY
Okay "What did Mark call the green gel in The Evil Within?"
I believe I called it Brain goop
*wrong answer*
awh dammit
UHHH
*THINK CHILD*
The good stuff?
*wrong answer*
GAWD DAMMIT
GREEN GOOP? *happy ding* YEAAHHH
OKAY THANK YOU
In the final episode of The Evil Within, what did Mark say books were for?
BOOKS ARE FOR NEEERRRDDDSS
I just remember have to remember what I'd say now
and it's pretty accurate to what I'd say then, maybe?
*happy ding*
yes thank you
"Which game did Babyplier appear in and got cake?"
That was Among the Sleep I beliieevvveee....
*happy ding*
Yes okay
"If Mark were to become a teacher, what subject would he teach?"
OBVIOUSLY American History
Because my ability to recall events that occured in America is immpeccible
*happy ding*
Thank you
"Tiny Box Tim is-" *cute voice* My Little Biscuit
*happy ding*
"In Vanish, what made Mark jump?"
UMMMM
A) The Monster C) The steam pipes D) Nothing B) Everything
I'm pretty sure everything did????
Because I'm a big bubble blowin' baby
*happy ding*
yesh
"In the Impossible Quiz, what question did Mark get wrong and fail the quiz during his first playthrough?"
I DON'T KNOOOOWWWW
HOW AM I TO KNOWWWWWW
I DON'T KNOW I GOT N O LIVES L E F T
EENY MEENY MINY MOE *Mark gibberish*
*happy ding*
*ECSTATIC SCREECHING*
O K A Y
WOOOOOO
"In Surgeon Simulator, which operation did Mark rage the most on?"
It was the doUBLE KIDNEY GAWD DAMMIT
YEEEESSS
*One of Mark's heartfelt speeches*
awwwwwhhhh
(and)
(ya know...)
(I just sometimes have to reflect and...)
(Use that as motivation and justification to keep moving forward)
(Because 2 1/2 years I've been doing this...)
(All day everyday...)
(It's the only thing I've cared about so far in the last 2 and a half years)
(and it's a big thing to care about so...)
(It's-uh- nice to be able to keep going)
*ingame mark and irl mark teary eyed ;-;*
(so either way, that's enough rambling from me)
(you get a lot of rambling from me as- uh- enough as it is)
(just seriously, thank you guys so much for...)
(everything...)
(As always...)
(I'll see you)
(In the next video...)
(buh bye)
awwwwwwhhh
Well thank youuuu
You see- this is why- this is why I love playing these things
and there's actually two more parts to this but I'm not gonna play right now because I don't have much time
and this video's already gonna be late but-
It's just-
This is why I play these games because they remind me!
You know they remind me- I've been doing this a loooong time like a loooong time and I know
there's been people on YouTube that have been there longer than me
BUT
THAT WAS 2 1/2 YEARS!
And when I said that, and it's almost FIVE and that's almost like...
M A N
so tha- TWO YEARS AGO
so much can happen to someone in so little time
and it's turning into so much happening in so long of a time a-and
so I-I don't if this game is a little rough I LOVED it!
I love it!
I love it when people make me things!
Chica's coming over! Hi Chica!!
I LOVE YOU
I love it! Ya know...
I just love doing these things and I like seeing like
all these amazing things. I love being reminded of the things that I've played in the past...
*Emotional Markimoo ;-;*
I-I really do!!
I just really love it all and I love the fact that it's still here!
And I- you know
eeeehhhhhh
I've become known as the guy that- you know
cries on camera and like
I'd- you'd be- it's so funny how many Youtubers I run into that that's all they ask me about
I just- you know-  I wanna- I wanna like-
*Markimoo.exe has stopped working*
You know I just-
I'm just- you know- I'm happy...
I'm happy to be able to do this
And I'm happpy to have so many memories...
I'm happy to have so many memories to look back on
And I'm happy that I'm still making more!
YA KNOW
And even I'm gonna look back a few years from now and Imma look back at this!!
These are why I play this cuz I can look back and remember
*happy yellling*
AHHHH okay alright
Aaahhh I'm gonna get out of here before I get too sappy about it
Thank you everybody so much for watching thank you so much for making this game, I wanna see more!
I WANNA SEE MOAR
I WANNA SEE MORE THINGS THAT PEOPLE MAKE FOR ME
I know there's so many it's so hard to find 'em nowadays because there's so many
There's so many pieces of fanart being made and there's so much stuff
You know, post your fanart to the Deviant... Deviant Art page it's still there
I'll put it in the description *giggles* it's been there since the beginning!
I never even really said how appreciative I am of the moderators that RUN that!
THANK YOU!!
I remember some of the oldest pieces of fanart...
AAAAAAAHHHHH STAHP IT
OKAY ALRIGHT
IMMA GO
*sniffles* AAAAAAHHHH
alright but thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for being here with me
for SO LONG!
and thank you for supporting me
and REALLY! get these games to me! Get these things to me I wanna see 'em I wanna see 'em all...
I really do...
so thank you everybody so much for watching
and AS ALWAYS I will see YOU...
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!
AAHHH (Fades out)